there are no justified resentments and
this is difficult to get but one that I
believe very strongly in if you carry
around resentment inside of you and I'm
talking about the person that you lent
money to and hasn't paid you back the
person in your life that you feel was
abusive in your life the person who
walked out on you and left you for
somebody else all of the things that you
have justified in your heart and in your
life that you have the right to be
resentful about it those resentments
will always end up harming you and
creating in you a sense of despair no
one ever dies from a snake bite but it's
the venom that continues to pour through
your system after the bite that will end
up destroying you and as I think about
this idea of getting what you really
want and being able to attract it into
your life what we have to look at is
basically the obstacles that we have
conditioned ourselves I have never
believed that we need to be putting the
responsibility on someone else if you're
conditioned it's because you have
allowed yourself to become that if we
conditioned ourselves to believe certain
kinds of things and one of the things
that we believe and hang on to and and
live with is this whole idea that all of
the things that happen to me in my past
are what are keeping me from doing what
I'd like to do today so we hang on to
these things and we fill ourselves with
blame you say I'm the middle child I'm
the youngest child I'm the oldest child
you know I'm an only child you know if
you're the youngest child
you can say well you know I never how
could I be making decisions for myself
when I always had somebody else telling
me what to do my whole life if you're
the oldest well how could I be expected
to think for myself I always had to
think for somebody else and that leaves
the middle child
you know the classic identity crisis oh
poor me so everybody with their birth
order or with their mother like their
sister better or that we had enough but
we didn't have enough we had too much or
we lived in the north we lived in the
south I'm too tall I'm too short I've
got too much hair
I don't have enough hair now there goes
your life in this direction you just
watch - amazing clips from Wayne Dyer
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]